returned to orlando last sunday and dr
rivers was not happy he had a quarantine
for seven days
given it was an excused absence but he
got out today
and all the coaches have talked about
being so vocal on the bench
doncic floats it up and in chitchat went
back to the locker room with a hurt
ankle
and now they're up by one
doncic nails the three-pointer
luke dodges now 11 points and three
assists getting help
eight points for porzingis and dallas
with the lead after
they signed it back in february after
charlotte waved him his first seven and
a half years with charlotte
doncic again gets inside trying to draw
some contact
he thought he got hit as well airspace
to get the three
dutches season opening drives inside the
wages kind of holds on to the ball takes
some contact and banks at home
true all the time blame and the receiver
instead of saying
that was a poorly thrown pass doncic
puts it in
over zubats who was right on top of him
that he got tossed yep
doncic for three as the shot clock
expires
hardaway goes back up top dodge's
side step lays it up and then beautiful
euro step from doncic
gwad open but seth curry in the corner
all by himself
so they have options reggie jackson
comes in to help he either can lay it up
or toss it to a knockdown shooter
quad lennon inserted into the game the
last two possessions is like
take a break i got you gotcha has it
going again
now has 34. luca because of all the
shooting on the floor with him
that's bad defense that's great offense
but that's off that time paul george
made the play
that's a great look for beverly dacha
spins inside
flips it up and in
[Applause]
doncic fakes leans in bang shot is good
38 points for doncic
well just as mark said no shot blocking
at the rim
gives him the opportunity to switch
pretty much everything
doncic drives on jackson gets inside
lays it in easily
if you take a look there's luca just
doing what he should do try to score as
quickly as you can
got a good skill set and a terrific
competitive spirit about it
maverick's still alive doncic drives
gets inside lays it up and in it's a
four-point game gives it to porzingis
two missed shots on good leaves wide
open shots now doncic will fire three
and he knocks down his first triple of
the game great start for the mavericks
here tonight
much different story here in game two
doncic another has that advantage here
crossover oh i mean this is just
easy and beautiful and the refs don't
make bad calls now don't flip me over
like that i'm just saying
everybody's an actor out there lou
williams
in the game for the first run and
another triple is down for
dallas and a timeout into the hands of
curry
doncic on the drive takes so much
contact that big frame at six
seven luca really attacking
the clippers defense got inside for the
clippers just 38 and a half percent to
start the game they're just two for
eight from behind the arc luca doncic
answers
with a three on the other end nice easy
finish there
that puts that confident step back
talking to doc rivers before the game he
said that reggie jackson was probably
the only true
point guard on this team when you look
at pat beverly more like a two and
defender
terrific fine that time by luca
then he teed up the three ball knocked
it down four scores over 18
having a deep bench having a
championship coach a couple on the side
and clearly
uh yeah a couple on the side over there
including tyler is the fact that they
have a heart for defense
[Music]
[Applause]
shot clock at nine williams on doncic he
gets by him dodge it springs free
and scores it in the lane first two
career playoff games
a new nba record he just passed kareem
abdul-jabbar wow wow